in northern california this morning the
bay area is partly surrounded by a
series of major
wildfires threatening thousands of homes
and blanketing the region with dangerous
smoke
more hot weather today is likely to make
conditions even harder for firefighters
fires are burning out of control all
over california
including around a dozen of a thousand
acres or more
carter evans in vacaville carter what do
you see there now
good morning the wind has stopped for
now it's calm and that's good news
because it's keeping these flames from
spreading further
california governor gavin newsom says
there are 360 fires burning
statewide right now they come after
storms delivered more than eleven
thousand lightning strikes
and all of this during a record-breaking
heat wave
all right we gotta get out here i'll
follow you okay
fast-moving flames forced our cbs
sacramento affiliate to flee
with seconds to spare about 10 minutes
south firefighters worked to contain the
growing wildfire in nearby
fairfield it forced emergency
evacuations in nearby travis air force
base
and shut down a busy interstate so you
can see what firefighters are dealing
with as the wind picks up here blowing
this smoke sideways across the road
they're trying to keep the fire from
jumping right now but it's not just the
flames
the smoke is so thick it's hard to see
late last night flames tore through the
santa cruz mountains south of san
francisco
part of what's known as the czu
lightning complex fires
at least three of california's wildfires
are each now greater than the size of
twenty thousand football fields as many
areas swelter under record-breaking
triple digit temperatures
this mobile home park in vacaville was
destroyed among at least
50 structures that were consumed by
flames as the so-called lnu lightning
fire tore through the community
i woke up and the whole hill was on fire
i mean the entire thing was on fire farm
owner rhonda petrillo says she and her
family narrowly escaped
but much of her livestock was lost i
went outside
it was the roar of the fire that i've
never heard anything like that in my
life
what does it sound like like a
locomotive just continued it was
it was freaky scary now the covet crisis
could be making these fires more
difficult to fight and that's because
inmate hand crews usually help out in a
situation like this
but there are reports that those crews
have been severely cut back
to slow the spread of coronavirus tony
all right stay safe carter thank you
very much